brain that i didn't put them on on the poomsae
you can see your pattern is scored uh based on the number 10 so out of 10 is your is a one
uh as you can see it's split up into two parts we have our accuracy and our presentation of the
site so we'll start off with the accuracy first so uh your accuracy it's actually scored from
a four so from the number four uh you're actually marked during your uh presentation of your pattern
and then with that one any mistakes that you make whether if it's a minor mistake get a minus
of a 0.1 if it's a major mistake
you get minus 0.3 so i'll just let you guys know about the difference between the two
so with a minor mistake it's uh very very small thing so say we're doing a
out of block if it's not your shoulder height maybe it's a little bit lower or maybe it's a
tiny bit higher that's a minor mistake so that's a 0.1 a major mistake would be you're supposed to
do an outer block in the pattern but you forget and you say you do a rich hand strike instead
so that would be a major mistake
so with a minor mistake uh let's say pattern one for example there's about 20 steps
it's not uncommon to have up to maybe 14 15 mistakes in the 20 patterns uh sorry the 20 steps
so the reason for that one being uh it needs to be absolutely perfect to get uh
to not get a deduction of 0.1 so it's not uncommon to let's say there's 20 steps and you may let's say
15 mistakes so what would that be so we'll leave that there uh on this side and we'll come back and
we'll just calculate the squat at the end so uh major mistake say you're supposed to turn to the
left but you turn to the right that would be a major mistake so obviously we do want to try to
avoid any of these major mistakes so uh after we've done our pattern that's when we move on to
the presentation side so the presentation as you can see it's from a score of six uh this
six is actually split up into three parts so we have one two three here so with this one uh for
a score of two is your power and speed your rhythm is also a score of two and your expression of
energy is also scored out of two as well so we'll start off with the power and speed so with this
one whether it's your blocks your kicks your strikes your punches anything you are that you do
you need to be nice and strong and it has to be fast as well
so it's one thing to have a very strong punch or a very fast punch but it has to be both strong and
fast to get higher in that category the next part is your rhythm so the rhythm uh when you do start
your pattern there is a rhythm to the pattern it's not just really fast all the way through
it's not slow all the way through there's a slow fast slow fast kind of aspect to it as well
so you do need to kind of work on your rhythm and that's also scored out of two
uh the last bit is your expression of energy so what is expression of energy so that's basically
uh how loud you shout so how much intensity you have during your pattern as well so uh say you're
doing your pattern really well it's really fast and it's strong your rhythm is really great but
you're not shouting very loud or you can kind of tell the judges can kind of tell oh you're not
really uh confident are you you're a little bit nervous so that's why i really kind of
give every little bit of effort a shot so now coming on to this side so with this one for
color belts and black belts it's actually scored a little bit differently so if you're a color belt
you'll actually uh your average so where where the judges actually mark you from it's actually
from a 1.1 so this is your average so say you did uh you did all right you did average compared to
everyone else you'll score for one two and three it'll start from a 1.1 so that's totally enough so
come on here
If you're less than average in the judges' eyes, you might go down to, say for your power and speed, you might get a 1 or even a 0.9.
If you did really great, you might even get a 1.3 or a 1.4.
So each individual category, you need to obviously get as high as you can.
If you're a black belt, generally, depending on the competition, you will be scored from a 1.3.
So 1.3 would be your average that you start from.
So say your power and speed was above average, you might get scored a 1.4 for now.
Say your rhythm was only about average, it wasn't amazing, it might be just a 1.3.
But let's say you didn't shout very loud, so your expression of energy, your average was 1.3, it might drop to, say, a 1.0.
So...
With this one...
We'll come over down to this side.
So with this one, as I was saying, it's a total of 10.
So let's see.
For presentation, we had 1.7, 1.2.3, so you had a 3.7.
Let's say you made 15 mistakes.
So with this one, obviously, don't be too discouraged if you do get pretty high in your mistakes.
This is...
With the judges, we have three judges usually at the panel, and each judge, obviously, is very subjective, so from their point of view, you might have made a lot of mistakes, or you may have made not a lot of mistakes as well.
So that's why we have the three judges, and we average it out as well.
Okay, so...
Say we did our 15 mistakes, very small mistakes.
So if they're all minus 0.1, it'd be 1.0.
So you'd go 4.0 minus 1.5, which equals 2.5.
So this would be your accuracy score.
So with our presentation like before, we're saying we've got a 3.7 here.
So we add these numbers after the judges are finished scoring.
So you would get, for this pattern, a 6.2, which is actually very good.
So I'll just talk about it a little bit more now.
I'll talk about this number here.
So if you're a color belt, if you're a yellow or above, and you do your patterns, it's not uncommon, generally, for a color belt, the average is about a 4 to 5.
So if you get a number between 4 and 5 out of 10 for your pattern, that's actually generally considered pretty good.
So anything above that, you can consider yourself pretty good.
If you're a black belt, the average would say, because we're talking here about the higher presentation as an average,
anything from 5 to 6 is actually considered pretty good.
And anything over a 7 is actually considered almost world class.
So if you get a 7 for any of your patterns, you generally need to pat yourself on the back because you did an amazing job.
So that's...
We just went through our Punze scoring.
So just remember, accuracy is a 4.0.
Presentation is a 6.0.
Accuracy is judge during your pattern.
Presentation is after.
And then we get two scores that we add up.
And we get that number.
So with this one, obviously, say I was judge number 1.
I would give you a 6.2.
There was another judge on the other side.
Maybe he saw a couple more mistakes.
Then I did.
And maybe this one would be a little bit lower.
It might be a 5 point something.
Another judge on the other side.
They scored a little bit higher.
So we get three numbers.
And then we average that as well.
So I hope this helped you guys.
So make sure you enjoy your Punze competitions.
And any time...
Make sure, obviously, you report down your numbers as well.
So that's pretty much it.
So we're going to wrap this up.
Okay.
So minor errors, major errors.
We cannot pause your video at this time.
But you're going to be rating yourself live.
So if you see a minor error, plus, plus, plus.
And then major error.
Okay.
And then after the performance would be power and speed,
coordination of rhythm, and expression of energy.
All right.
Okay.
Thank you.
No problem.
All right.
Thank you.
Appreciate it.
Bye-bye.
Bye.
HALLOWEEN.
Hallo.
Thank you.
So now I go win these ones.